Elon Musk has the green light to build a
high speed underground transportation
route to Chicago's O'Hare Airport must
said yesterday his boring company won
the bid to build a system using electric
vehicles to carry passengers through
tunnels he predicted it would be ready
within three years
Chicago's Mayor Rahm Emanuel calls it
the fast lane to the city's future Dean
Reynolds spoke to musk and Emanuel about
the plan that promises to outpace
Chicago's famous L trains this animation
shows how Elon Musk's boring company
plans to transform transportation
passengers could one day travel like
this from downtown Chicago to O'Hare
International Airport gliding on
electric skates as many as 16 people
would be swept along at speeds well in
excess of 100 miles an hour making the
non-stop trip in 12 minutes compare that
to an hour of hell or more in a car
during Chicago's rush hour for the 45
minutes on mass transit for the same
journey mr. mush why why do you do this
it seems like we've been stuck in
traffic for decades I don't know a
better part of a century and there's a
lot of skepticism that this can be done
at all look there were doubters about
putting a man on the moon on anything
that's new there'll be doubters Chicago
Mayor Rahm Emanuel and the tech
entrepreneur turned billionaire
businessman musk say it's time to give
Chicago 21st century transportation on
Thursday they visited the proposed
downtown station which happens to sit
underneath the CBS News Chicago Bureau
effect if someone can even detect that
we're digging the tunnel underneath them
we want to buy the technology they
invented the sturdiness of the tunnels
is a safety concern and the disposal of
the tunnel
an environmental one but if the concerns
are answered must says digging could
start in three to four months and the
first passengers could be aboard in
three years 30 to 60 feet underground
musk is hoping to dig a tunnel in
California to showcase the technology
and is working with officials in the
Northeast Corridor on a similar idea
though red tape is slowing his progress
must certainly knows something about
being in a hole he just laid off nine
percent of his workforce at Tesla
because of a financial reorganization to
one liftoff but his space ex Rockets are
now part of the nation's exploration
efforts and musk remains bullish I think
this is something that's new and
exciting it's not just the same old
thing but America's about trying bold
new things or trying new technologies
that that are really gonna inspire
people for the future it's predicted the
system could carry 2,000 passengers in
either direction every hour with the so
called skates leaving at 30 second to
two-minute intervals the price 20 to 25
dollars or about half what a cab ride
would cost shortly before we spoke to
musk on Thursday he addressed the
possibility of the failure if we fail
well I guess me and others will lose a
bunch of money for CBS this morning Dean
Reynolds Chicago I'll have a Dean piece
dreaming big
look I support his visionary I know yeah
I do too and you know every time we see
the figure about laying off nine percent
of the Tesla staff I think it's
important to say that it's not affecting
the production staff that is still
working on those model three cars it's
my understanding that it was white
collar employees that were laid off
still it's a big it is a layoff and we
can't make light of that but he's still
on track for doing what he said he
wanted to do and he was here in New York
City was the soul deadening traffic wait
to get to he wouldn't mind if he
suggested that New York he's always
thinking always thinking big and if it
doesn't work he goes back and tries it
again nothing wrong with that